hallo zusammen wir machen heute
japanische Soufflé Pancakes ich zeige
euch eine gelingsichere Variante bzw sie
müssen ein paar Tricks beachten damit es
funktioniert aber wenn ihr euch Schritt
für Schritt an die Anleitung haltet dann
darf eigentlich nichts schief gehen ich
habe die das erste Mal vor ein paar
Wochen in Belgien gegessen die waren so
lecker ich habe direkt gesagt ich muss
das Rezept nachmachen so ich habe jetzt
hier Eigelb ich habe Eigelb von Eiweiß
getrennt und mein Eiweiß kommt gleich
erst zum Einsatz die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben stehen wie immer bei all
meinen Videos unten in der
Videobeschreibung das mache ich deshalb
damit ihr euch das einfach screenshotten
könnt einkaufen können und das Video
nicht so lange Atmen wird so mein Eigelb
kommt jetzt hier in meine Schüssel sind
nicht mein Schneebesen den ich rühre
dazu nehme ich dann als erstes damit es
nicht kommt nämlich als erstes Mehl und
danach Speisestärke und anschließend
gebe ich mich dazu und das verrührt ihr
dann einfach frei
[Musik]
so die Eigelbmasse ist fertig die kommt
jetzt kurz an die Seite so lange vorhin
bis eben keine Klümpchen mehr drin sind
dann macht ihr da alles richtig so und
jetzt gebe ich Eiweiß ihr braucht ein
Eiweiß mehr als Eigelbe das ist so
gewollt und dann könnt ihr mit dem
Eigelb vielleicht könnte es in eurem
Rührei weiterverarbeiten aber spart da
nicht dran denn wir brauchen jetzt eine
fluffige Baisermasse und davon nicht
wenig so ich gebe jetzt hier zu meinem
Eiweiß eine gute Prise Salz so eine
schlagen wir das Ganze und sobald die
Masse weiß schaumig ist lasst ihr dann
nach und nach den Zucker einrieseln
so die Masse könnt auf jeden Fall noch
steifer sein weil guckt mal das läuft
mir hier alles runter aber an der Stelle
kommt mein absoluter Top Tipp für die
perfekten so viel Pancakes und zwar
weinsteinpulver das ist nicht das
gleiche wie Weinstein Backpulver was sie
aus dem Supermarkt kennt genau aus dem
Grund habe ich mir auch vor einem Jahr
vorgenommen ich möchte Weinstein bei mir
im Onlineshop anbieten weil es ist voll
das amerikanische Ding aber irgendwie
ist es in Deutschland noch nicht so
angekommen obwohl Weinstein so genial
ist es macht z.B in Cookie zeigen macht
das die Cookies viel zarter es macht dir
die Baisermasse viel viel fester es ist
so krass was das alles bewirken kann
sogar beim Putzen ist Weinstein voll das
Ding und davon gebe ich jetzt ein
bisschen da braucht ihr gar nicht so
viel jetzt mit zu Baisermasse das kommt
wieder zurück weil wirklich wenig bewegt
hier schon sehr sehr viel die Masse wird
viel fester also es wird ganz anders
als wenn ihr da ganz normal weiter
schlagt und viele machen auch in den
Pancake Teig noch zum eigelbackpulver
das lasse ich weg weil das ist ja auch
gleichzeitig ein Backtriebmittel so und
da kommt gleich nachdem ich das noch mal
zwei Minuten verrührt habe ganz zum
Schluss noch ein Spritzer Zitronensaft
rein
[Musik]
so die Baisermasse ist fertig sie ist
extrem fest eben durch unser Weinstein
und die Zitrone brauchen wir eben damit
es wirkt das braucht immer ein bisschen
was an Säure und dadurch wird die
Baisermasse auch noch mal ein bisschen
fester ich könnte mal über kopftest
machen so so selbstbewusst wie ich über
meine Masse rede ja es klappt das klappt
das klappt so auf jeden Fall ähm mache
ich jetzt folgendes ich habe ja hier
meine sehr sehr Eigelb Masse das ist
auch so gewollt und jetzt müsst ihr ganz
langsam und wirklich peuge abfüllen die
Baisermasse zur Eigelbmasse geben es
gibt da wirklich erstmal nur Mini ein
bisschen rein und dann nehme ich mir
auch mein Schneebesen und mach so ganz
langsam Bewegung ein bisschen das
verbindet und später wechsel ich dann
von Schneebesen auch auf Teigschaber
weil das dann noch mal ein bisschen
zarte ist aber so kann ich jetzt erstmal
die Eiweißmasse mit dem Schneebesen so
ein bisschen lockern er die eignet weil
die ist ja eben 10 und man sieht schon
sieht sich immer so wahnsinnig
kompliziert an ne aber eigentlich geht
es relativ schnell und einfach und
sobald alles miteinander verbunden habt
ist die Teigmasse auch schon fertig
[Musik]
jetzt sollten wir schon relativ zügig
die Pancakes ausbacken damit sie nicht
an Luftigkeit verlieren und dafür nehme
ich jetzt einfach meinen Topf der hat
jetzt ein relativ hohen Rand das ist
eigentlich ganz cool weil die mehr Raum
umso besser ist es für die Pancakes
unten gut verschließbaren Deckel braucht
ihr so und jetzt habe ich den Herd
eingeschaltet nicht zu heiß weil sie
brauchen schon viel Zeit um zu stocken
ich bin jetzt hier bei Stufe 55 gleich
hoch auf 6 und dann nehme ich jetzt mein
backtrennspray und spröde einfach so ein
bisschen Fett in die Pfanne und ähm dann
nehme ich mir ein Teig Portionierer so
ihr könntet es auch mit einem Löffel
machen aber so habt einfach schon mal so
perfekte eigentlich die perfekte
Ausgangslage und jetzt Schichten wir das
immer so nach und nach ist immer so ein
bisschen Teig einmal in die Pfanne mit
viel Abstand weil so ein bisschen
aufgehen werden die noch gehen die gehen
natürlich ein bisschen in die Höhe aber
auch so in die Breite und jetzt stapele
ich einfach erstmal so zwei scoops
übereinander und wenn ihr mögt und das
gleich stockt nach zwei drei Minuten mit
geschlossenem Deckel könntet ihr noch
einen dritten scope oben drauf machen
aber das ist echt persönliche Präferenz
man muss ja auch zusehen dass das Ganze
innen stockt und nicht innen irgendwie
flüssig oder rot bleibt
[Musik]
so es gibt jetzt noch einen Trick also
die Pancakes sind jetzt bei mir so
ungefähr eineinhalb Minuten drin gewesen
und dann nehme ich mir jetzt einfach ein
bisschen Leitungswasser also wirklich
nur so tropfenweise und gibt das hier
noch in die Pfanne übrigens draußen sind
wieder unsere lieben Bauarbeiter da
hinten bisschen laut genau das Wasser
darf jetzt hier einfach vor sich hin
verdampfen das hilft noch mal den
Pancakes eben stabil zu bleiben und das
ist Ganze eben vernünftig auspackt
[Musik]
also das mit dem Wasser ist wirklich ein
wichtiger Part und das verdampft auch
relativ schnell daher immer wieder
Wasser dazugeben und ich wollte euch
jemand anhand dieses Beispiel zeigen was
passiert wenn ihr es einfach zu früh
umdreht mir das Gefühl habt ihr kommt
schon unten durch es hat sich schon die
goldbraune Schicht gebildet aber ihr
müsst euch wirklich so viel Zeit lassen
bis es sich relativ einfach umdreht und
hier ist z.B jetzt ein Fail weil es
einfach eine Minute zu früh war und der
andere ist super geworden genau und der
muss jetzt auch noch mal mit
geschlossenem Deckel so ein paar Minuten
es kommt tatsächlich auch immer auf eure
an wie lange ihr braucht einige sind
vielleicht nach fünf Minuten schon
soweit und können drehen andere erst
nach acht bei mir waren es jetzt
wirklich acht bis neun Minuten und dann
habe ich erst gedreht und genau ihr
müsst einfach mal selber ein Gefühl für
kriegen
[Musik]
also ich würde jetzt lügen wenn ich sage
ich weiß nicht wie sie schmecken weil
wir konnten gerade unsere Pfoten nicht
von der Pfanne lassen haben direkt schon
probiert nicht schmecken echt gut also
ich war immer gespalten der Meinung weil
ich das so auch so viel Aufwand für
Pancakes und lohnt sich das überhaupt
dann habe ich sie ja dein Belgien
probiert in so einem Laden der war
übertrieben gehypt ja da war ich einfach
nur so boah die muss ich zu Hause
nachmachen
die schmecken so fluffig man muss gar
nicht kauen das geht richtig im Gaumen
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass der
Weinstein einfach bewirkt dass die
Konsistenz ist wie sie ist weil immer
wenn ich Weinstein benutzen Rezepten es
macht Dich immer Sinn aber oft dann ist
es eben genau diese wolkenartige
Konsistenz und das habe ich jetzt gerade
auch können die Weg Wecker und hier
haben sie wirklich verfluchen das ist
ohne ihn esse ihr bekommt übrigens fünf
bis sechs also eher 5 von dem Pancakes
hier raus und wenn ihr euch an alle
Angaben an alle Tipps und Tricks haltet
dann gelingt euch das doch jetzt ja
gesehen wenn es so vor als hätte kann es
auch mal in die Hose gehen wichtig ist
natürlich auch eine gute fand es immer
so Kleinigkeiten auf ankommt aber wir
sind schon extrem luftig ich habe mir
das mit Ahornsirup und mit Puderzucker
gegönnt paar frischen Früchten und ich
werde das jetzt auch hier zusammen mit
Sarah weghauen oder also ich wünsche
euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und
wenn ihr mehr solcher Rezepte sehen
möchtet abonniert meinen Kanal und
schreibt mir gerne auch was ihr sehen
möchtet ich habe zwar schon fast 650
Rezepte auf meinem Kanal aber das z.B
hatte noch gefehlt und bestimmt auch
ganz viele andere also bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss
[Musik]